our final panelist tonight is on tone
and booty who's the cultural counselor
for the French Embassy in the US and
although we're very fortunate that he's
headquartered here in New York he
actually has responsibility for all the
United States in terms of cultural
affairs and higher education and as he's
also the permanent representative French
universities in the US before taking up
his position here last fall until now
was the cultural counselor in Spain for
four years and before that he held a
number of government positions including
concealed technique in the cabinet of
Prime Minister Dominique Nevada where he
was in charge of international cultural
and economic affairs and francophonie
before he began his career in public
service until now had an interesting and
unusual trajectory as a student he
started out as a brilliant young
mathematician and a student of
engineering at the Ecole Polytechnique
but he decided to change and follow his
passion and study literature at the
ecole normale supérieure we where he
worked on a thesis unproved under the
direction of Ultron companion so we will
now hear from Antonin Butley thank you
for coming intrusion and I'm sorry I was
late I just flew in from Paris boys I
was i my my arms tired I'm very
impressed by the quality of the
panelists here so I'm sure my work will
be very easy because they have said
everything and much better than I ever
would so we'll just make a few personal
remarks and tell them what are my micron
visions I think that if French matters
it's simply because it is a global
language it's not only a local European
language French is a dynamic world
language as we can see from the recent
winners for example in of the of the pre
no clue which is a one of the most
prestigious French literary prizes at it
Jaime or Jonathan littell for example
have different mother tones and they
choose to to to write in French as did
samaire betrayed before them and when
she still on the rise I think
as we can as we can see in recent
political events the wave France has
taken the leadership in in North Africa
or Middle East for example thanks to its
deep historical and linguistic ties in
this region I think we can say that a
lot of events taking place right now in
the world are taking place in French I
think that even events have a mother
tongue in this sense in the in Detroit
21st century France is being transformed
from within by former phone writers from
its immigrants from each winner who
comes in France and who transforms
French like for example Marian di who is
a very famous French writer living in
Berlin but his father came from Senegal
and it's just an example among thousand
so I think that there is a real
dialectical relationship between phones
and the world it's on both sides I mean
so dynamic exchange it's not just from
imposing culture and language on its
former colonies I think it's these
former colonies when reach the French
language and the French culture and I
would like to to to show you naughty
girl from The Guardian the UK rajan
which is the pleasure the title is
french is too important to be left to me
the class from profiles and it's I love
the Brits you know just because this and
undoing who say which who wrote this
article I don't know him but he says he
is not a specialty of fungal phone or
from profile but he gives us a very
simple reason for that and he says I'm
quoting him whiting in French from my
work road to send it over to to Quebec
has much to teachers in Britain about
the hyper complexity of the
post-colonial world and i think it's
it's remarkable that that the garden
could publish this argument
about about French I think that yeah I
believe that in order to understand the
world as it is today you have to speak
of French or Spanish other languages or
at least you have to know people who do
so and English is a global language of
course but it does not mean that events
take place in English or around the
world I think that if wench is a global
language this is not only because of
political events or or geopolitics the
fact i was mentioning before but I think
it's also because of more fundamental
reasons France and America share a
common heritage and of course this has
to be with the the connection with the
enlightenment values and I saw that Bill
Clinton side in 1995 in a lecture at
Georgetown University he said that
America is an idea and of course then he
developed and he said that this idea was
freedom and that the shape of America
was the kind of consequence of idea and
I think that we could say the same about
France I think that France is an idea to
it would not be the same maybe it would
have to see more with equality than
freedom maybe something more complex
than i could say tonight but i think
that the whole structure of the country
and all the relationships between the
people can be understood as consequences
of ideas as for example the importance
of the states in forms or many other
things that I mean actual themes
and for that I think that it makes
French a very global language as English
is and something more maybe is that you
probably so that foreign affairs are
very important in France I think a lot
of foreigners in firms asked where to
buy the importance in the daily
newspapers of Foreign Affair our
teachers okay and pages and everybody in
France has an idea about political
affairs I mean sometime it's a very
simple idea it's not very sophisticated
and everything but it's part of the
month or landscape of a French regular
citizen and it means that somehow france
french language integrates a part of the
world maybe it's not not not a perfect
way of course but it there is a part of
that and if fine if french-language
integrates the outside world that means
that French is a global and coherent
system and I I dare say a point of view
on the world in a light nitin sense then
the line is had the idea that every
being was kind of a point of view on the
world and of course some have broader
than others of course a human being will
have a broader point of view on the
world than a tiger for example but every
being has one and I think that French is
the global perspective on the world and
on history so these two countries friend
France and America are to global
perspectives and the world and I think
that therefore they have a lot to share
on international affairs and on every
subject for fundamental reasons and not
only for accidental reasons
people taught English or around the
world it does not mean that people think
in English or around the world and we
can communicate in english but i think
we cannot insert ourselves into another
world view without a certain language
and even if words are translatable and
they are not always by the way but
thoughts and worldviews are not in the
world they exist in the blanks or in the
spaces between words and these blanks
and these spaces between words are not
translatable means the difference
between Google and a human soul for
example and Google will never translate
the Blanche and the blends and the
spaces between words and that just why I
think Google translation just doesn't
work this blends and the spaces between
words other system or are the structure
that assemble the interpretation of the
words in the same sense that you talk of
an interpretation of a music sheet for
example and in other words you cannot
get the sense of some reality without
the language that encloses it I could
quote Walter Benjamin in the task of the
translator quoting Nietzsche the closer
we the Rosa will look at a world the
further it Lutz back at us form i think
that the experience of a certain
language is like music it is another
dimension of open throughout your life
and nothing can replace it if you don't
have it because when you learn a second
language you have a whole new world view
and chateau by on side to have a certain
language is to have a certain soul and i
think that for the reasons i said before
french is a spacious soul I don't say
that it's a comfortable soul for example
he don't say that it's an optimistic
soul and maybe you saw a survey in
France that proved that French people
who are more pessimistic than the Afghan
people for example but it is i think it
is still an interesting southern soul so
more concretely what is the situation
now in the US of course we we all heard
and we all had many concerns about the
situations especially for example in
Albany and yeah the initial plan was to
this activate or dismantle the the whole
French department there and i went there
and told to his president Philip of
French of SUNY Albany and it's plain
that the reasons were all more than
everything else financial because of the
budget codes and cuts and everything you
already know and we proposed to try and
enhance the number to try and help
enhance the number of french student
there because it's always a key for the
protection of French departments and we
learnt as I'm sure you learn to the few
years a few days ago that finally they
will keep the minors in French that we
did not keep the majors in French
unfortunately the this is the bad point
but the good point is that the tip the
minor and therefore there will still be
a French department so we take that as a
starting point and from this point we
will try to help this department to
increase the number of French students
so this is an example maybe a night when
it example but the situation is kind of
paradox here because there is an
increasing of the number of students who
are studying French in the US this
increasing is five percentage here and
in the
same time there is a big increasing of
collaborations between French and
American universities in all disciplines
from French literature to
nanotechnologies or history on biology
even at the highest believer we are
talking about a lot of dual degrees and
even dual phd's 707 thousand articles
have been co-written and cosine by
French and American strollers so the
situation of collaborations between
French and American universities is
rather good and we have a lot of
instruments helping this increasing as a
puf we can talk of that later maybe in
the questions and at the same time there
is a threat on many French departments
in the u.s. because of project codes and
when I see this kind of threats I mean I
don't take that personally because it's
not only French I mean it's also Italian
and it's all languages except for
Spanish which which is not exactly a
foreign language or or Chinese for other
reasons and it's not only languages it's
also humanities that somehow are
threatened in the u.s. University so we
don't take it personally but it doesn't
mean that we don't have to do we don't
have to react and I heard many people
asking if it was important in this
context to keep french departments and
French studies in the universities and
people are doing that as there are many
collaborations in sciences and
everything it might prove that we don't
need it and I think that we really need
it and I mean what would be an important
university in the US without
mathematicians well would it be possible
in in two
very high research high-level research
in physics or economics or biology
without any math department it wouldn't
and I think that it is because math is
the language is the language of sciences
and I think that it's the common point
between french and math there are both
languages French is not only the people
that's the language that people are
torturing are talking in the in the in
the streets of Paris it's a language but
it's always it's also a language for
history philosophy at knology literature
etc etc and of course I don't pretend
that every ethnologist would have to
speak French of course but I think that
it is important that some of them do and
that they could talk of literature and
history and ethnology in French and with
their colleagues I think that French
studies enrich all disciplines it's not
an isolated field of learning and I
think that the the French department of
Columbia is is really the perfect
example of of this here I understood
that every French stroller a very French
teacher was also involved in another
department of Columbia University it
could be history or ethnology and so and
so and it's of course very very clever
and very important to do so because it
protects French department and it shows
the the deepest links they are between
French studies and the other disciplines
we will in the French Embassy we will of
course encourage every French department
in the US 24 forge this kind of links
because these links give value to French
departments and protect them
interdisciplinarity centers and of
french and francophone studies will be
for example encouraged you know that we
recess today 15 interdisciplinary
centers in the US and each time it's one
it's at least two departments deciding
to create a French French programs
together and then means that it involved
it involves always more than the French
Department and I think that it could be
useful to think of it as a protection or
tool 222 faster French departments in
the US but of course there are many
different situations in the u.s. in the
you in the in the French departments and
innovating solutions have been proposed
throughout the US I was recently in a
channel for example a nutshell they are
thinking of creating new kind of PhD I
want to enter the details now but there
are a lot of different solutions that
are proposed and that's why I would like
to create a task force composed by
influential friends of French culture
and of innovative leaders of French
departments to imagine together the
University of the future and the place
of French within it no discipline exists
in isolation and no language exists in
isolation the French language today is
an expensive global language it's a
window on the global world thank you
very much
you